le major sami whalen est venu discuter
de harcèlement et d'inconduite sexuelle
soldats et employés civils sont entassés
dans le petit auditorium de la base
militaire de petawawa en ontario
le major loosen rappelle à tous qu'ils
sont des représentants avoir des
ambassadeurs du canada et plus ces
rencontres d'information au lieu dans
les bases militaires partout au pays
elle vise à prévenir de nouveaux
problèmes des conduites sexuelles au
sein de l'armée canadienne
la branche terrestre qui représente
environ la moitié des effectifs des
forces et résonne en moi et nenê les
ovaires ici risque c'est une directive
qui vise nos 43 mille soldats et
employés civils affirme le colonel
telium
c'est très sérieux le commandant de
l'armée a envoyé une note interne à tous
les officiers supérieurs le 15 mai
dernier pour leur demander qu'ils
reconnaissent qu'ils sont collectivement
responsables de ne pas avoir prévenu les
problèmes des conduites sexuelles
la note a été émise après la publication
du rapport dévastateur qui exposait le
problème systémique d'inconduite
sexuelle au sein des forces
on ne sait pas si la marine et les
forces aériennes vont imiter l'armée du
défunt ne me sens de ganja de bécasses
action nous devons tous travailler
ensemble pour avoir du succès dans
l'armée dit-il
et c'est impossible lorsque nos membres
s'affrontent entre eux à cause des
conduites sexuelles
c'est ce coaching nous devons changer la
culture à l'internât joue-t-il ça ne se
fera pas rapidement mais ça commence par
ces rencontres où l'on ordonne aux
soldats de cesser d'utiliser un langage
vulgaire et dégradants ici philippe
leblanc radio canada toronto